كانت هناك مشاكل في بعض
المطارات ، إنها معزولة ، فليس كل
يوم من أيام الأسبوع ليس كل أسبوع
في الصيف ، كما تعلم ، يجب أن تتوقعه
لأن التعافي
استغرق أه تعلمون أن السرعة التي جمعت
كانت تتحرك في الواقع أسرع بكثير مما
توقعه الناس
.  سأعبر في الواقع عن بعض
التعاطف مع المطارات ، وهي
المرة الوحيدة التي تسمعني فيها على الإطلاق أقول
هذا ، لكنني أعتقد أنه قد
فاجأهم ،
ستتم معالجة هذه المشكلات ،
لقد طلبت أمستردام من شركة klm
تقليل رحلات جاتويك الآن  نطلب من
الناس
تقليل الرحلات الجوية إلى مطار هيثرو ، أعني أن
هناك ثلاثة مطارات تأتي هناك
الآلاف من المطارات حول العالم ،
لذلك نختار من بين ثلاثة مطارات أحب أن
أختارها بالمناسبة ويمكنك
إضافة دبلن إلى هذا المزيج الذي واجه
مشاكل ولكنني  لقد مررت بكل
هذه المطارات التي سافرت إليها عبر
المعدة ، لقد سافرت عبر أمستردام
هيثرو دبلن ، أنت تعلم نعم إنها
أكثر انشغالًا ولكن ليس الأمر كما لو كان يصور
أنها فوضى هناك كل يوم
الأسبوع الذي
توجد فيه مشاكل سيتم
معالجة المشاكل هي المشاكل مع
شركات الطيران التي غادرت وتسريح
والآن لا تستطيع العودة أو المطارات التي
فعلت نفس الشيء أو كلاهما مذنب أه لا
أعتقد أن نكون منصفين هناك شركات طيران بها
مشاكل  بالإضافة إلى ذلك ، لكن لدي الكثير من
التعاطف مع شركات الطيران التي
قامت بإجازة وتسريح أشخاص خاصة في المملكة المتحدة
لأنك إذا نظرت إليها في
سبتمبر من العام الماضي عندما أنهت حكومة المملكة المتحدة
دعمها
لشركات الطيران إذا نظرت إلى من كان
كان 38
من شركات الطيران المدعومة لا تزال تستفيد من
38 موظفًا لدينا من موظفي الخطوط الجوية الذين
كانوا لا يزالون يستفيدون من برنامج الدعم
وقد تم قطعه بين عشية وضحاها
كما تعلم أن المملكة المتحدة كانت في الواقع بطيئة للغاية
في التعافي في الربع الأخير من
العام الماضي والربع الأول من  هذا
العام فقط في الربع الثاني
بدأت الأمور تتحسن بالفعل